[Music]
Plus bounce back to the Grammy red
carpet because we caught up with a few
of our favorite couples that what it did
you on stage the weekend performed with
Daft Punk but after the show he and
girlfriend Selena Gomez tried to be
incognito as they dance the night away
at Rihanna's after-party at 1oak
nightclub Keith Urban performed with
Carrie Underwood but was missing his
missus Nicole Kidman was in London for
the British Academy Awards aka the
BAFTAs a little bit yes because it's I
mean what are they are just on the same
night and other opposite sides of the
globe John Legend and Chrissy Teigen
spent the time before the red carpet at
home with daughter Luna I understand
you're thinking about to join into the
family well we want to yes Oh coming
sooner later little girl it's so
beautiful I mean the pictures he's so
precious yeah yeah she's little chipmunk
face to now and she's teething so bad so
her cheeks are so swollen and I love it
it makes her even cuter right I'm bait
hill and Tim McGraw will be making their
upcoming soul this old tour a family of
beer
well your daughter's be joining you on
your choice oh yeah nobody out Gail
Simmons I got a life now you know there
grace' be twenty Maggie's and eighteen
Audrey's fifteen so they got other
things to do than hang out with mom and
dad and exciting news about another star
couple retired New York Yankee shortstop
Derek Jeter and his supermodel wife
Hannah announced that they are expecting
their first baby a little girl
congratulations and we could actually be
talking to Hannah about it on Wednesdays
et that'll be cool
you